[Musique]
les français sont inquiets
la situation sanitaire se dégradent la
récession la plus sévère des pays du g7
des classes surchargées des enfants
perdus de vue
c'est comme je connais la loi je sais
que la loi est comme ça alors la loi
considère les occupants comme des
résidents après 48 heures passées dans
le domicile
dans le cas présent le couple squat
cette maison depuis plusieurs semaines
drogue proxénétisme ventes illégales
torture des prisonniers des oreilles ou
des queues coupées d'une cruauté d'une
barbarie inqualifiable
voilà bon réveil à tous quand la loi
protège l'agresseur au détriment de la
victime
c'est qu'il faut changer la loi donc la
loi vachon donc là les squatteurs ne
sont pas dans leur vrai droit si la loi
les protège faut qu'on fasse quelque
chose vous serez candidat vous pour
l'heure je suis content que pose la
question parce que là j'ai gagné une
caisse de champagne j'ai parié que vous
me poseriez la question alors que j'ai
500 fois répondu vous choisirez gens le
manufacturier japonais bridgestone a
décidé de fermer définitivement son
usine de béthune dans le pas-de-calais
il emploie 8 163 personnes dans la
fabrication de pneus une fermeture
complète de ce site c'est un assassinat
et c'est un assassinat prémédité
prévue de longue date je pense que le
capitalisme de transformer tout en
objets et qu'il y aujourd'hui
effectivement un capitalisme planétaire
qui veut vérifier la totalité ce qui
existe une décision un brutal sur la
forme incompréhensible sur le fond est
une trahison de la confiance que l'état
et la région au de france ont placé en
bridgestone
on est dans l'usiné depuis des années ce
n'est pas possible sans mettre en oeuvre
des formes de protectionnisme
ce n'est pas possible si on était six
heures dans la france avec les
spéculateurs avec le rassemblement
national
alors moi je
non mais pas de caricature c'est faut
pas caricaturer et cissé alors qu'août
d'investir ça va leur coûter beaucoup
plus cher de fermer le site et ça va
prendre des années
parce qu'en france on part pas comme ça
c'est pas prends l'oseille et tire toi
j'aime le tour de france c'est un
spectacle gratuit avec des gens
admirables qui font un sport admirable
et bien jamais je re imaginer qu'on
attaquerait ces gens là une armée de
canard
dix mille palmipèdes en mission en route
vers une rizières inondées
ils sont les héritiers d'une tradition
ancestrale en asie ils nous aident en
mangeant les escargots pommes et les
résidus des corses de riz qu'ils restent
dans le champ après la dernière récolte
au passage les canards piétine la paille
de riz ce qui permet d'aplatir le sol et
de facilités de labourage interdire le
passage du tour de france annulé le
sapin de noël
en fait les maires europe ecologie les
verts c'est tout ce qui amène un peu de
joie ou de fait qu'ils interdisent ils
sont pires qu'idéologue ils sont rabat
joie en allons pas à fixer à la fête
d'aidé et chats et le maire d'eauze et
la première c'est que les minorités
active et agissante sont extrêmement
efficaces et l on est contaminé tout le
débat public
enfin qu' en france dirais qu'il faut
pas de sapin de noël sont relayés par
les médias
pourquoi vous en parler autant moi quand
j'étais enfant j'allais avec ma mère
j'attendais ce jour pratiquement toute
l'année on allait choisir le sapin parce
que c'était tellement important pour moi
ça s'appelle les comédies wild wild life
je vais y arriver compliqué photography
awards donc le but vous regardez on
dirait que l on fait un petit site
j'avais pas le sentiment d'être un
criminel qui faisait du mal à l'humanité
il faut s'adapter mon vieux ça vous
paraît tout aussi enfin ça fait du bien
pu être dans la politique parce que
franchement si ça c'est de la politique
alors là je ne sais pas ce que c'est que
ça c'est quoi
j'avais pas que vous pariez 20 des
caisses de champagne devais parier que
vous ne parlerez de complotisme bavaud
la deuxième caisse peut s'envoyer
bah oui on vous avez perdu